What do we do first?
So, the recipe calls for 150 mil
but I will ask YiaYia to tell me when to stop.
This is her own olive oil that she's made
from her own olive trees.
Wow. Holy cow.
So, YiaYia.
(speaks foreign language)
Ready?
It's going in.
(speaks foreign language)
She's going to tell me when to stop.
Oh! Okay, she said stop, she said stop.
Perfect.
Okay, so...
Now, in here, I have garlic and onion.
Chopped up small.
Chopped up fine.
So that's all going in.
Into our olive oil mix.
Then, we whack in the parsley.
And also...
The whole thing?
Oregano.
She's shouting at me not to put too much oregano in.
(audience laughs)
Okay, well...
Just a tablespoon.
(speaks foreign language)
So she's saying a teaspoon of pepper. Ground black pepper.
Goes in.
I've definitely put at least a tablespoon, if not more.
(audience laughs)
And what about salt?
That's fine.
YiaYia likes to go for it.
Oh, she's saying "Go for it, go for it".
I did, thank God.
I love salt.
Me too.
So now, she's doing some indentations in the aubergine.
Because we're gonna fill the aubergine.
Ooh.
Sorry, that's eggplant to you.
Also, we're going to slightly stuff it
with the olive oil, garlic and onion mix.
Ooh.
So it gives us a little bit of space to put this into.
So the flavors sort of suffuse a little bit easier.
I like that.
And we're gonna do that with all of the veggies.
I never even knew about this.
I've never done this.
So, we are placing the vegetables in the tray,
ready to go.
While you're stuffing as well,
sort of just dunk them in the bowl of olive oil mix.
Kind of just sort of completely cover them
in the olive oil mix.
I don't know how YiaYia does it, but...
(jessica alba laughs)
I'm gonna just...
I hear you girl.
I know how to stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's good, it's good.
Yeah, these veggies are stuffed and smothered.
She said it's looking really good.
She can see them.
She likey, grandma.
She likey, she likey.
YiaYia approves.
Phew.
YiaYia says "Yes."
So now we dunk the potatoes and the carrots
into our olive oil mix as well.
So it's everything is completely covered.
Back into the, we put it all into the tray.
The potatoes, the carrots, the mince,
everything in the tray.
Look at how beautiful this is.
I mean, and you know what?
And it looks gourmet.
It should look very colorful.
Look.
Yeah, that's what I...
As you say, nothing to see here.
(audience laughs)
Back with the town.
So now, YiaYia is chopping a tomato.
She's chopping a tomato
and she's just going to place the slices
of tomatoes into the tray.
Oh yeah, no, we just put the whole...
Oh yeah, we just threw them all in there.
Anastasia, will you ask YiaYia if you had sort of, like,
an end of the week vegetable,
could you do that?
I'll ask her now.
(speaks foreign language)
(audience laughs)
She said "Yes."
Phew, okay, all right.
Don't forget, sorry, one last thing.
A little bit of water goes into the tray.
Oh, so it steams.
About half a glass of water goes in.
Oh, I never do this.
So it doesn't stick to the bottom of the tray.
Done. I'll pass over to Iska for the tzatziki.
Iska.
You really did leave an extraordinary blueprint
for something that maybe is an adventure
we should all seek in life.
This is so much more than a cook book to me.
that being said, I have loved tzatziki my whole life.
I've eaten my weight in it.
And yet I've never made it.
Me either!
So, Iska, please, show us the way!
Okay.
Look, here's my grated cucumber.
And I've put it in a tea towel
because we need to get rid of all the water
in the cucumber, basically.
So if you squeeze it downwards,
and you should get some nice green juice coming out.
Oh yeah, yeah.
If we're going to (indistinct).
Ahhh!
All right.
Look at it now.
And then there's more.
Okay, you've got it.
Okay, and then you need to get your bowl of Greek yogurt.
Yep, we have that, it's already in.
So I've got 300 grams of Greek yogurt here.
Got it.
Cucumber's going in.
And then two teaspoons of grated garlic,
or two garlic cloves, that goes in.
Got it.
Pinch of salt?
Pinch of salt.
Quite generous with the black pepper.
Oh, good.
Or a big pinch of black pepper.
(indistinct)
I love eating like, purees and then just pouring
giant amounts of cracked black pepper into.
Yep, squeeze of lemon.
I love when people do it in their hand,
like, to catch the seeds.
They look so sexy and confident.
Oh yeah, the seeds are in there.
Okay, I'm folding it all together.
This is awesome.
This is beautiful.
Okay. Next?
So then I'm just going to put that out,
out on to a plate.
Like, can I eat it right out of the bowl?
I know!
(laughs)
Oh here, perfect, yes.
Here?
We've got bowls.
Like that.
Okay, perfect.
And then you finish with a little sprinkle of dill.
Everything looks better with a garnish.
True story.
I mean, look at that now.
That looks profesh.
Super profesh.
Okay?
And then the final pièce de résistance is the Greek olive,
which has to be a Kalamata olive,
which goes in the middle.
I mean...
It may not have looked pretty while I was making it,
but come on, look at the end result.
Yeah.
I don't mean that, but...
It's great!
(audience applauds)
It's my first tzatziki, I'm so excited.
Okay, by the way, I gotta taste it now.
Hold on.
I know, I wanna get in there.
It's going right, I'm salivating.
(audience laughs)
I really, I really do salivate.
Yum.
Oh my God.
It's so good.
What?
That is so beautiful.
Okay. Hold on.
I wanna read one thing from the book.
Because I think it sums up this entire experience.
Anastasia and Iska,
YiaYia and Jessica.
One of my favorite things that I read in your book
is from the foreword.
It says "A recipe not only accompanies us through life,
"it can outlive us if we arm the next generation
"with the wherewithal to make it.
"An edible baton."
Aww.
Thank you so much,
That's so tender.
for putting that into the world.
And Jessica,
I think that's so fitting for what you've just accomplished.
You are arming the next generation
with a baton that will take care of our children
and save our planet.
Thank you.
Thank you so much Anastasia and Iska and YiaYia.
Thank you for bringing us into your world.
(audience applauds)
I can't wait to get this book!
I am stealing this book after this!
There you go.
I am so excited, this is amazing.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com for today's full recipe,
and to learn more about everything we were doing today.
This beautiful book "Grand Dishes"
will also be celebrating The Honest Company all day
in honor of Jessica's IPO.
Thank you so much, you guys.
(upbeat music)